[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMRIT SANJEEV: Hi, everyone.
I'm Amrit.
I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
And today I want to talk
about push notifications
and how internet developers
are hacking to get the delivery
rates a little
higher in the region.
So let me talk about one
of the stats about India.
We have about 340 million
plus smartphone users.
And it's growing at a
16% year-on-year growth
rate, which means that your
apps have a great chance
to acquire more users and have
great business in the region.
But along with this
business, you have--
also comes with a
lot of competition.
So there is a greater need
to have a better engagement,
as well as delighting
your users.
And push notifications
is one of the mechanisms
a lot of developers use in
order to engage your users.
When it comes a push
notification delivery rates.
Some of these patterns
in India actually
affect the notification
delivery rates.
One of them is
the user behavior.
Until recently, data plans
were very expensive for us
in the region.
And people had tended to
have the habit of turning off
mobile data when they
are not using internet.
So when they go out
of a Wi-Fi zone,
they just turned
their mobile data off.
And that changes the
behavior of something
like a time to live parameter
for your push notification.
If you have a really
short one and the person
has turned the data
off during that period,
your notification
never gets delivered.
Recently we had new
carriers who have come in
and have reduced the
data cost drastically.
And now this user behavior
is slowly changing.
But it hasn't changed enough
for you to ignore this change.
Secondly, we have a lot of
devices with custom behavior
or custom Android bills,
where your notification--
and because of
battery optimization,
they kill off these
notifications services.
They sometimes force
close apps, which
avoids the app from ever getting
the notification delivered
to it.
So that's another problem.
Your time to live
parameter, if you actually
increase it by, say, from
four to eight hours, you
see a drastic improvement in--
or a large improvement
in notification delivery
because you might
end up overlapping
with a Wi-Fi usage time.
So things like that make
it very interesting.
Like in any other region,
notification frequency also--
the number of notifications
that are sent in to the users--
also affect.
And people do get irritated
and turn off notifications
if you do it too many times.
So using collapsible
keys and things like that
are very important here.
Now I want to talk about three
design patterns that developers
have actually tried out
for various use cases
to improve
notification delivery.
One is bucketing
of notifications.
This gives you a better
understanding of your user base
and how people are-- how
each of these buckets
actually work better for you.
Let me explain that.
The mechanism that
they've developed here
is that there's a job that--
a periodic job-- that runs,
refreshes the FCM token,
sends it to the server.
And when the server
gets the data,
it actually keeps a user
FCM token mapping along
with the recency of update.
It'll also take the time
stamp of the update.
Now when you send out a
campaign, what they would do
is they would split
it based on recency.
Say for example, you would
send your push notifications
in the first batch
to all the tokens
that were updated in the
last say, seven days.
Then the next batch would be
to update from 7 to 31 days,
all the tokens that got
updated in the last--
from seven to the 31 days.
And third batch would
be 31 and above.
What this allows is
that you can fine tune
each of these buckets--
the parameters for
to improve
notification delivery.
You also have a better
understanding of who
your users--
which users would
get the notification
and might react to your
notification better.
And your-- and because you have
a lot of tokens, which are not
updated frequently, or the users
never send that update cycle,
you don't end up calculating
that into your notification
delivery and miscalculating
the effectiveness of push
notifications.
The second one is
basically where
you have, again, a
[INAUDIBLE] job that comes in.
It checks whether
a notification was
delivered to the device
from the last run or not.
If not, it'll go to a REST
service, pull the notification,
and then display to the user.
This is fairly simple to use.
But you have to ensure that
this does not excessively wake
up the device.
So this is not the most
effective or efficient way
of doing things.
But still works for it.
The last one I
want to call out is
data messages to the schedule.
In a case where you want
to send a message like,
hey, there's a sale that's
going to start at 12:00.
And you want to show the message
to [INAUDIBLE] for next six
hours, you have 20% off on this
device, or on this service.
Where, instead of
sending it on 12:00
and hoping that most of
the users would receive it,
what they will do is they
will send this message
maybe two days before with
the last time to live.
And they-- as a data message.
So the app would receive it.
Then based on the schedule
that's within the data message,
they would schedule
a job to come up
at exactly the right time
and display the message
to the user, which means at
12:00 a lot more of your users
will start getting that data.
[BEEPING]
SPEAKER 1: That
would be times up.
[GONG]
All right.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]